house is currently at uh University
complexity and cryptography I just want
to take the occasion to congratulate
profel for the very recent amazing news
that he's an ICM fellow
we could the subjects
foreign
welcome to this third day on
cryptography and uh
it's really fun to be here any
particular talk about this topic that uh
Yani and I have been working on for the
last few years and we're both new to
come over complexity and meta complexity
and it just turns out that there's so
many amazing connections between the
fields of cryptography and chromographic
complexity and I hope that uh there will
be many many more
so since I assume most of you are not
cryptographers my plan will be to start
off by giving you a very quick review of
what's been happening in cryptography
for the last two thousand years
and then we'll move on to some more
recent results
so cryptography for the last
few thousand years it really was in a
dark time when I referred to as the dark
ages of cryptography
and roughly speaking the way crypto
proceeded was as follows would you have
somebody who invented some scheme
typical tools for encryption
and maybe claim that known attacks on
this encryption schemes fail then maybe
managed to even argue this that's known
attacks don't work then we employ a
scheme
often in very critical stations often in
military applications and of course
after some time given how important
these applications were the scheme was
broken at that point we have to go back
here come up with a new scheme uh often
it was a patch at some point it was a
revolution we have to really come up
with a new paradigm and it went on and
on like that
and this is really how things proceeded
up until maybe the 50s when Shannon
tried to get a uh really try to get a
scientific foundation for cryptography
um and the real Revolution came in the
work of different Hellman from 1976
incidentally is also the year I was born
when they came up with this notion of
what is today called a one-way function
in fact you already call it that in in
their original paper
this paper which starts off with a
humble first line we're on the brink of
revolution in cryptography you know they
were right
uh okay so what is the one IF function
function is a function that is easy to
compute so given an input X typical
think of this as a random string
it's easy to compute the function to get
f of x but given f of x it's hard to go
back
and when we say hard to back go back
would mean there's no polonial time
algorithm that given f of x can compute
the the pre-image X
and easy means it can be computed in
polynomial time
the most typical example of a candidate
Warrior function is multiplication so
multiplying two large numbers is easy
but if I ask you to to factor the
multiplication of two large numbers that
is somewhat hard
and if they're primes to believe it's
very hard
so the formal definition is follows
we're looking for a function f that is
polymer time computable and we say it's
one way if for every probabilistic
polymerton attacker a there exists a
negligible function such that
if I sample random X apply the function
give the output to the attacker the
probability is able to find out pretty
much any pre-match should be negligible
so very small okay
uh in crypto we sometimes use the notion
of uniform algorithms PPT probabilistic
polynomial time algorithms sometimes in
non-uniform circuits for basically on
any of the results or none of the
results that are going to talk about
today this will actually make a
difference so I'm going to stick to PPT
but it really works for non-linear from
PPT also and typically it's easier to
prove things from non-new from PPT some
of the results that I will mention were
first proven for non-uniform and then
later on when it was extend it to
uniform too
okay so why did they come up with this
function
well this notion of a function the
intuition that they had was this is
something that should be minimal for
cryptography
right for any reasonable Forum
encryption scheme or any kind of
applications of cryptography
we need something like one awareness we
need to be easy to encrypt something but
it should be hard to recover the uh the
message from the encryption okay so it
kind of has a flavor of one awareness in
it
and somewhat magically
it turned out actually over the years
people managed to show
that their intention was completely
right
this is actually required for most of
the central task and cryptography
basically everything uh everything that
requires computational assumptions
requires warning functions we have a few
uh
few things that not necessarily required
actually like their knowledge is not
care what it requires it and
obfuscations there's a few examples of
things that don't necessarily required
but basically everything we use on the
internet today requires one of functions
and even more magically this was much
harder to prove and it took many many
years to do it
One Way functions turn out to also be
sufficient so if you have one of your
functions we can get secure private key
encryption scheme that's like kind of
the key killer app that we wanted we can
get pseudonym generators digital
signatures authentication schemes those
are the things that we use on the
internet today to communicate all the
time right so these are things that
we're running
uh
planning all the time on internet okay
so one of your functions are necessary
and sufficient to do it
so uh it's uh safe to say that whether
One Way functions exist is the most
important problem cryptography without
200 functions no secure complication on
the internet okay unless Quantum stuff
can be done but let's uh
ignore that for now
the world that we live in today
everything would would change and we
would not have secure communication on
internet if we don't have any money
functions
so do we have oneary functions
uh
okay before I move on let me mention
there's a bunch of things I'm not going
to talk about today or but tal will talk
about in the second part of uh today so
there are much a lot of cryptographic
tasks or a few at least in very
important one and more advanced so
they're not included that we don't know
how to get from any functions like
public encryption something called WS
transfer applications and so on so forth
that's not gonna be the focus of today
so we're talking about kind of this
these things that I will later on refer
to as midi Crypt these are the kind of
central symmetrically Primitives in
cryptography
foreign
functions
as I said we use them all the time when
we communicate on the internet so uh
uh we need to get them from somewhere
and today the way we get what we
function is we have a bunch of
candidates for them so as I mentioned
the most
famous one is multiplication
multiplication and uh and the factoring
based money function that results from
that there's another one basically
discrete log lattice problems and some
more heuristic type constructions
uh these are actually the most typically
used on the internet
um
and so far they're all fine they're not
broken right uh and and we use them
but there's always a question of time
all right so you know not broken now but
maybe somebody will break them and there
is this beautiful quote that by Joe
Killian quoting Sylvia McCully that
cryptographers seldom sleep well at
night why because we can wake up any
morning and uh factoring has broken and
the whole internet is down that would be
pretty bad
now I personally think there are some
experience correlations here it might
not be the only reason why cryptography
don't sleep there could be some
self-selection here but
let's not discuss that
uh
the point here is that things could be
broken and that will be problematic and
in fact if pumping computers are built
then factor in discrete log would be
killed off
not these problems we don't know how to
break them yet with a Content computer
but I haven't been around for that long
so some of the things that we had in
this crypto cycle actually survived for
several hundred years and today there
can be broken like this right so
um
so the central problem that we're going
to be focusing on today
is whether there exists some natural
complexity theoretic problem that
characterizes whether one of functions
exist
that does exist some nice clean
complexity theoretic question
that tells us whether quality functions
exist or not
this is not a new question in fact this
question goes all the way back to
different helmet's paper
because they were also already kind of
concerned they proposed this discrete
log based body function but obviously
that wasn't very satisfactory so they
actually proposed what approached
towards this
and the approach was well they observed
that if one of the functions exist
that and P cannot be equal to p
this is Trivial right so
you know
the weakest assumption that we can use
is to can we get the one a function from
assumption and P is not equal to P or MP
is not inside PPP
and that was an approach that they
already proposed
this has sometimes being referred to as
become referred to as the Holy Grail of
cryptography trying to prove this body
functions exist based on uh just
assumption the minimal assumption NP is
not inside BPP
um
now very early on there were a few
candidates based on this approach so
people tried to use MP complete problems
to construct money functions
that actually led to constructions that
often uh became uh broken using
interesting techniques so it like
actually led the field forward in a
significant way
but very quickly it let a lot of
skepticism and they started already in
1979 through the work of brazar that
showed that it seems unlikely in some
very specific ways to base what we
function on the Assumption empty is not
inside BPP
and uh so what prasar showed was in fact
if you want to go for something stronger
something called a one-way permutation
then it's actually unlikely uh to show
this using a
using Black Box reductions so using
touring reductions you cannot base one
of mutations on uh MP noticeaby
but one representation is is too much
that's not a necessary condition that's
actually a much stronger object about it
functions
so subsequently there's been a lot of
work people trying to extend these
results to one-way functions
fortunately it's still wide open
so there's a bunch of very very nice uh
separation style results but they don't
always get all the way to other
functions
the only way to get to one of functions
is to consider even more restricted type
of reductions and if you consider real
touring reductions in fact none of this
result called the wife
um so the question is still wide open
both on getting getting the construction
and getting a separation
now if this question is too hard
we can say maybe try to get take a more
granular look at what it means to kind
of Base what a function is clean
complexity assumptions
and
looking at impact lazio's worlds
provides a very nice perspective
so as you've already heard
in rahul's presentation about
impagliazzo's worlds
is very influential paper Define a set
of possible worlds that describe which
kind of a complexity theoretic world we
live in
so I'm going to follow kind of the same
type of picture like uh Rahul did where
on the the left I'm stating weak
assumptions and assumption becomes
become harder and harder and that when
we travel from left to right we're
moving through possible worlds okay
so on the left here
something is
got messed up here in the okay we'll see
so on the left we have uh this is
supposed to be here we have the world
where LPS inside uh P MPS inside BPP
solar MP problems are easy this is the
world we call algorithmica so in
algorithmic can we can solve all mp uh
MP heart problems
we'll move to the right we get uh
eventually the situation where MP is hot
on average
and so the world heuristic guy is a
world where NP
is the worst case hard
but uh hard but easy on average
so here is the cap we can solve all MP
problems on average heuristically but
it's still worse gets hard so it's a
pretty decent world right
algorithmically
then we get to pestiland here in
pestilian NP is is actually hard on
average
so it's pretty shitty we can't really
use algorithms so well for everything
but unfortunately we don't have one a
functions
okay so we don't have cryptography but
NP is still hot on average and that's
why it's called passy line it's what's
Imperial called the worst of the all of
this world's a very pessimistic state so
first
and then we have mini crypto what the
functions exist but we don't have these
stronger things that public encryption
and cryptomania is the world where we
have even the strongest form of uh of a
crypto public encryption OT we're not
going to be here Carl is going to be
there okay so we're going to focus on
things here
okay
I'm gonna add one extra world because
every good talk needs to have a new
definition I don't have any new
definitions so I'm going to instead
create a new world so that's
uh and uh so what I would like to
add as a world here is uh a world where
actually X is inside BPP okay
and that's what I call randomalia it's
uh where Randomness has a unreasonable
power right so using Randomness you can
solve all of X that's around the Malia
in in Pakistan algorithm kind of contain
everything so I'm going to restrict what
I call algorithmica to be between uh
randomalia and heuristica
okay so let's see now what the Holy
Grail amounts to the Holy Grail amounts
to going from hardness of NP in the
worst case to oneary functions
so that requires eliminating
heuristic and passilat
so if I would like to prove this in the
Holy Grail I need to kill off these two
worlds okay I have to show the heuristic
it's impossible and personal is
impossible so that's a pretty you know
love to go we can also try to show
something easier to just kill off passy
loud
that means I would like to show that I
can get to one refunction from the
assumption that NP is just hard on
average so the MP contains some problem
that's hard on average
and now the reason I introduced this new
world
was because we can also even more love
their goal which we need to say look
that's nice but what does it mean to go
all the way from here this very crazy
assumption very simple assumption
minimum assumption X not in BPP two
one-way functions
foreign
really should be the easiest to rule out
okay and it's an embarrassment for all
of us that nobody has managed to rule
this uh it's like so unreasonable that
Randomness would allow us exponential
time speed ups but we can't rule it out
okay so in today's talk
what I'm going to do is to present some
natural problems that characterize money
functions okay and you've already heard
about this in many of the previous talks
so the spoiler here it's going to be
complexity style problems okay and
that's why it's in this Workshop
uh
we're gonna then use this
characterization
to actually elucidate exactly what it
means to eliminate worlds to get
learning functions in this implicatable
setting
so what I'm going to argue actually is
that if you would like to understand
what it means to get 20 functions and to
eliminate these worlds
this you really need to to study meta
complexity you need to study common
complexity
and finally we're going to discuss a
little bit about how to use cryptography
so these insights from here to actually
get new insights into computational
problems regarding converter complexity
this was never our original goal but it
just like popped out on the way
okay so let me very very briefly Now
quickly you know review some of the
Notions that Rahul and Radha Rahul
mentioned uh I'm gonna go over them in
more detail but as you remember from the
previous talks
we have this very nice
complexity Zoo stealing a turn from the
second rule
so we have a few different Notions of
commercial complexity that appeared in
the literature from the plain one which
is just a unbounded one of where we say
that the common complex string is the
length to the shortest program that was
a string
so time bonded Notions so KT would T is
in the exponent here and we think of t
as being a polynomial
it's a Time bounded notion where I'm
requiring the program to Output the X
within time T of x t of length of x
then we have the 11 Commodore convection
notion where instead of bounding running
time I'm uh charging for it in the in
the cost so I'm looking at the smallest
program uh plus logarithm of running
time some charging logarithmic in the
running time and then we have islander's
complex notion where I'm instead adding
uh charging for time additively so we
have a few different Notions here and
there are actually even more variants we
have a conditional variant of these
things when we look at conditional
complexity so given a string X and some
uh string Y what is the smallest program
to outputs x given y for free
what do you really mean in the Top Line
instead of mktp what are you going to
call that uh sorry this there's no T
there do you see a t
let's change it quick
or maybe not because my computer is uh
okay
okay so we have a also a bunch of
variants with the conditioning and
furthermore as Rahul mentioned there are
even further variants because I can look
at
either the problem K where I'm looking
at the problem of computing the
commercial complexity or a decisional
version which is this mkp or mktp
or even more refined I can look at a
decisional version where which is
parameterized by some thresholds so I'm
asking for instance is the Morgan
complexity greater than n half
and now we just need output yes or no
but this looks kind of complicated we
have all these different options and
indeed the relationship as we heard
before the relationship between them
isn't uh really known and uh so it's
kind of frustrating in so many different
Notions
so what I would like to argue is
actually that at least if we go to the
the setting of average case complexity
Things become much cleaner
and we can suddenly see relationships
between these Notions some of them will
turn out to be exactly the same
and some of them are very different
and there's a good reason for it
so
uh
high level some of the kind of key
insights that I like to draw
it's the character is exactly what it
means
actually to take these jumps and to
eliminate worlds
so let's start off with a
uh the Holy Grail okay so the Holy Grail
was to go from
NP in the not inside the BPP to one-way
functions
there are two characterization what it
means to to do it the first one is going
to be that you need to show that mktp is
MP complete
and you need to show worst case average
case reduction for mktp
in order
to actually to prove the Holy Grail this
is exactly what you need to do
okay so let's see the first Direction so
let's say the mktp is a complete and
complete and you have a worse case
fabrication reduction
so if amp is not inside P for PVP then
we know that mttp since it's MP complete
is also noticed at BPP
if we have a worse case average case
reduction
then we also know that mttp is average
case hold
and finally two results that we'll see
later on
show that worst case hardness or average
cases mktp implies money functions
turns out that the converse also holds
because of this equivalence of mktp on
average with one of functions if you
would like to go from here to here you
have to prove these two things
so method complexity is not a
coincidence here
if you would like to prove the Holy
Grail you need to prove that mktp is FP
complete so this whole vein of work that
Rahul was talking about is necessary for
proving the Holy Grail
yeah do you do you actually need to
prove it's NP complete under some
reduction just that it's like not in P
assuming MPS yeah so empty complete in a
non-blackbox way or what I mean right
so yes this is okay it doesn't have to
be through a Cooperative reduction it
has to be through some like non-black
post reduction
now it turns out but if you change your
problem to m a m say m c KTP so this is
a quotational version this problem turns
out to actually be and be complete
and uh so now the only thing you need to
do the only thing is to present the
worst case average case reduction for
this problem
if you get a worse case average case
selection for this problem then you've
also shown the holy grail and again this
is necessary so this is exactly what you
need to do
so where's the establish your structure
for this problem is exactly what you
need to do to get 20 functions from the
from amplitude
now let's move on to the simpler problem
just ruling out pastilla if I would like
to go from average case hardness of NP
to 1A functions
again we can get a very clean
characterization
and what it amounts to is showing that
on average the uniform distribution is
the hardest for the MCC KTP problem
so what I mean by this is to say if this
problem is hot for some distribution
then it's also hard for the uniform
distribution that's exactly what you
need to do to relate pestilent
and finally we can get the similar
statement for uh ruling out all of these
worlds
and now it's in terms of the MKT Little
T P
so really meta complexity is not a
coincidence here it's not just a tool
that's useful it's actually necessary
this is what we need to uh to do in
order to understand the relationships
between these worlds
okay so as I mentioned all of this
relies on these characterizations of
one-way functions using meta complexity
so uh
uh so the goal here is we'd like to find
some natural problem whose average case
hardness is equivalent to the existence
of money functions and all of these
results that I mentioned here are going
to follow from that
and uh so this was first actually
achieved in a work by uh Levin
where he introduced this concept called
like universal one function so using
versus when we function is a function
that is one way
it's a specific function it's one way if
one of functions exist
so that is a construction that is
complete for money functions
the only problem is that this
construction is kind of is very tailored
to this exact task not a very natural
problem right so it's not the problem
that gives much insight into
um where the quantum functions exist
so a few years ago uh Yani and I showed
that um
the KT problem
also has the same uh
his property so the KT problems recalled
time boundary complexity with respected
uniform distribution so looking at the
uniform distribution the simplest
distribution if this problem is hot on
average in that case what if functions
exist and it's an if only if
and you can also phrase it as mktp with
a threshold of n minus log M so the
decisional version with no threshold
and
the last two years there's been a bunch
of other problems shown to also uh be
equivalent like the conditional one uh
like KT the 11 one uh and uh and very
recently even just unbundled Google
complexity and here what's cool it's
there's actually not respect to the
uniform but with respect to any
distribution okay it's cool they speak
to any but there's also some negative
aspects because of the fact that it's
with respect to anyone will get back to
that towards that
but the point here is right now we
actually have a bunch of different
problems in fact basically all of the
ones almost all of the ones that only in
in the previous slide and they turn out
to be actually equivalent with respect
to the uniform distribution so KT in
this exponent ckt and K Little T here 11
Commodore they're all equivalent with
respect to uniform distribution and
they're equivalent to existence so many
functions
it's an awesome open problem already
mentioned by your own uh whether we can
get a non-meta complexity problem
characterized money functions okay all
of these are you know we have a bunch of
different characterizations but they're
really
no they don't pay maybe the same in the
worst case but
from the outside it's a big K here
everywhere so yeah yeah what is this can
you repeat the mktp and in Brackets n
minus oh so this is a decisional version
our time to decide whether commercial
complexity is greater and My slogan or
smaller than n minus log m
so you don't have to compute it just
decide
and is the is the length to the string
oh
actually I'll get back to this very
shortly
now
in this complexity Zoo yeah
that's like a bit forward by Haley and
Rahul like they also show uniform
distribution over okay
average case hardness is also improved
as well
no I'll talk about that soon
so actually it's uh we didn't mention
all of this
problems right there was a few problems
left in this complexity zoo in
particular
complexity mktp with the big T where you
add for running time
and this question of different
thresholds there's also space I'm going
to ignore space
but it turns out that once you go to
this mktp
the problem is actually not equivalent
but it's equivalent to something else
turns out to actually fully characterize
cryptography in nc0 one who functions in
nc0
so it's really kind of crazy how these
like Notions actually turn out to
either someone over the same or in some
of them characterize some other very
natural primitive like one functions
computable and c0
so uh it's a beautiful uh work by uh ran
and Santa Monica
showing uh showing this and uh in fact
Alan nerdal also managed to show that if
you look at the conditional version that
also turns out the character is
cryptography of zero and that is
actually MP complete so you can now
actually get a very nice
characterization on of exactly what it
means to uh kind of show the super Holy
Grail of going from nautical to P to
cryptography and zero and that is in
fact to just show up just your worst
average case reduction for this problem
okay and one can also uh characterize uh
log space uh log space body function
using space bounded Notions and we also
had a version of of this using a more
ugly converter complex notion based on
based on space
uh but the conclusion here is that now
we actually can see some structure into
this complexity zoo and it's almost like
it's kind of crazy how these Notions
really turn out to really fit into the
cryptographic Notions
there's a picture that you've showed
about the absolute universe and the
relation to from
next uh are these uh were they already
known or is this also the connection
themselves on you wait no no this is
actually this is like this all these
things are consequences by the
characterization since your character
can characterize money functions you get
these these things so now we have a very
clean complexity theoretic kind of a
meta complexity interpretation of these
questions about the photography can be
based on uh on average case holderness
it works based on us
foreign
and the final thing I wanted to mention
here I'm not going to go into this
result at all and the rest of the talk
is that now let's go to this question of
what happens when you change it
threshold
so I said well the threshold is Big you
want to decide whether convertible
complexity is
you know greater than money slogan or
smaller and money slogan then we get 20
functions what happens when it changes
threshold actually we actually don't
know if this problem of mktp becomes
easier or harder it's not that purely
clear
if it's harder to decide it when the
thresh is small or large
on average we can now actually give a
definitive answer turns out that
actually when a threshold is smaller the
problem becomes a lot harder
in a very clean way actually turns out
that when a threshold is small like poly
log
this will characterize some exponential
one-way functions
when a threshold is large we know it's
only a normal money function and
actually it's a smooth line it's like
when you move the threshold you get a
stronger and stronger down you get
stronger and stronger when it functions
so in a threshold is a forget that
square root then you get cozy polynomial
money functions and so it's a very clean
uh
at least statement that the threshold so
again it's like mind-boggling how can it
be that this notion actually characters
the quantitative hardness of one-way
functions
when you move the threshold down you're
saying you get a stronger hardness
section so the problem is easier right
that's what you mean
the problem is harder because it's
equivalent especially like The Brute
Force algorithm is probably like faster
than what we know when it's depressions
again because uh
hardness of this is equivalent to the
existence of sub-expective sort of money
functions
a bit
okay
yeah I guess yeah yeah so the problem is
yeah it's it's easy to break it but it's
yeah the hardest assumptions
yeah sorry yeah you're right
oh that is very hard too sorry yeah no
thank you
yeah yeah what just remember here is
like when it's fully log it's equivalent
to some exponential any security
functions
or
so so if you have one new functions and
it's a zero you get automatically phds
but I don't think you have the full
stretch right uh like that I don't think
it's known as to get um
that's like a purely now we're in a
crypto regime right that's like now we
have when it functions let's see what we
can do from that
yeah
any other questions
the key Point here is I'm not going to
talk about these type of things I'm
going to focus on uh uh on
uh on this part here I need some
implications to impacts as well
and so uh so what I'm going to do now is
to show
and this initial result uh how we
characterize what it functions using KT
and I kind of discuss some of the
extensions to KT and actually not this
but uh
some other extensions okay
I do want to actually mention the sub
linear hardness stuff
um even though I won't have time to talk
about it here I think it's uh it really
shows in a very beautiful way actually
the the connection between crypto and
some of the literature in in meta
complexity in particular these results
very uh strongly rely on this beautiful
vein of work uh by oliviera and Santana
on hardness magnification so this is a
fascinating concept or fascinating
phenomenon that happens to these meta
complexity problems where it turns out
that for some of these problems just
assuming sublinear hardness
uh for one of these meta complexity
problems you can actually get a very
strong hardness
so supplement holders for in particular
you know in the in our setting it will
turn out that it's actually enough to
assume that the mktp with this small
threshold is hard Against sublinger Time
to get some exponential money functions
okay and so there is a beautiful line of
work on this cinematic complex
literature if you haven't read it you
should look into it
the less reference
uh I don't know actually that should be
there
what we're going to talk about today now
is um
uh I'll try to give you a higher level
overview of this initial results and
then sketch a little bit about uh some
of the other ones
so the result we're going to show is
that one a functions exist if and only
if the t-bounded complexity problem is
mildly hot on average
foreign
so let me now you know go over a little
bit more detail this notion of logo
complexity because we kind of went over
it very fast so uh
as you know the commercial complexes
string we Define it as the length of the
shortest program to Output the string
so formally we're fixing some tour
machine Universal turing machine and
we're looking at the length of the
shortest with the Eric called
description with a description consists
of a program and some additional input
um The W such that
um the universal machine on M W outputs
X
this notion has lots and lots of amazing
applications but it is uncomputable
and this is why uh we typically consider
this time-bounded notion
which is defined exactly the same way
except at the running time of the
program is cut off to T on the length of
the uh the input
so thank you for the remainder of the
talk think of t as being n Square okay
these results actually work for any T
that's greater than let's say one plus
Epsilon n but uh think of n Square for
Simplicity to not have to you need to
work a little bit more to work with
small t
so the key question that we heard a lot
about in the last few days is whether KT
can be efficiently computed
okay so it goes back to I wrote the 60s
we heard earlier that maybe it goes all
the way back to the 50s
and and it's closely related to the mcsp
problem
and as Rahul mentioned yesterday what's
really cool about this problem
is this Parable conjecture that goes
back to the 50s to 60s that basically
says there is no better algorithm for
this thing than brute for search
and uh
it's kind of like looking forward on the
fact that we get this connection when it
functions Maybe
it shouldn't be surprising because there
are certain things in crypto for which
we don't have any we don't have any
better attacks in brute for search so if
you want to get equivalence to crypto we
really need to start off with a problem
that has such a property
right whereas actually many of the
candidates we have for crypto like uh
factoring discrete log and latest
problems we do have non-trivial attacks
so it's very unlikely as they're going
to be complete so really need to start
off with a problem that has this type of
character and so it does
or at least we believe so
now let me continue since we're close to
the break Let's uh
Muse a little bit what but why this
problem is so important
I guess their own said yesterday that
mcsp
e may be more important than such and
not clear who wants to sign off sign on
to that but
I would also argue that this KT problem
is super super fundamental it's really
much more important than just a question
of complexity of this this is really
about the world that we live in okay so
what what would happen if Katie is easy
okay well number one
we can do optimal file compression right
that's great we we can optimize we can
compress our files in a clean way very
very nice but it doesn't change
fundamentally what that we live in right
yes I'm here very like right now I'm
very uh hand wavy but yes I do mean the
search version and actually it turns out
that by this characterization they say
you actually have decision to search
equivalents and that's going to follow
from actually connection with
cryptography but uh so yes indeed when I
talk about here I mean the search
version what I'm giving a string C you
shouldn't just output the um the
complexity but also find the short
program that that generates
um this is what actually the 60s they
refer to as a constructive version of
The Commodore complexity problem don't
just tell me what it is but give me a
witness
okay but something much more interesting
happened but I claim is that science
becomes easy okay
at least if we believe Occam's razor so
what does outcomes razor say well this
is what it says it's not it's written in
a in the short supermodel complexity and
traditionally are not are not to be
multiplied without necessity so what
does that mean that means that if you
have a bunch of observations okay and if
you give me an explanation to why these
observations happen the simplest one is
most likely a truest
okay and this is how science proceeds
right if we have a simple explanation to
some physical observation this is most
likely the uh what we believe to be the
truest scientific theory
now if this is easy
then we don't need really scientists
at least you know
we will still need us to get the data
we'll be the slaves for the uh for the
computers that will just find the best
models we will go and collect and the
computers will will just do all the
interesting stuff we might still get to
that with you know this uh gp3 style of
things
even if it's not optimal but luckily
we're not fully there yet
but if kit is easy that's we're doomed
okay there's nothing for us to do except
to collect the uh evidence
um so this is a very fundamental problem
we really need to understand it
okay
uh we're going to talk about the average
case holders of this problem
and it's really fascinating when you
read this uh structure brought survey
about what happened is Soviet Union in
the 60s
this was the 60s remember that was
before average case holders was
considered in the uh or average case
complexity was considered in the
complexity literature turns out that
they only looked at it okay they didn't
call it average case complexity they
looked at for this particular question
complexity they looked at what they call
the the frequential version
does there is an algorithm that computes
KT
for a large fraction of x's
okay that's exactly the same as saying
what is how hard is it on the uniform
distribution right if you can compute it
for large fractional inputs that's the
same thing as saying you can compute it
for a high probability of a uniform
distribution
and obviously a very simple observation
was made
that this problem
cannot be super hard at least if you
just want an approximation
okay so if you want to just get an
approximation within let's say login
then it's very easy
to actually uh
solve it with high probability
in fact you can solve it with
probability one minus one over n so
almost probability one
by just outputting n the length of
string
and this relies on this observation that
we saw
that by a very simple counting or most
strings actually have convocal
complexity close to m
so if you just want to be within login
just output n and you're good to go
okay so if you look at the approximate
version you cannot assume this is very
very hard
uh but can you do better than one must
want to run
and that's a problem that they left open
at least according to tracting rods so
can you beat this one over on trivial
bound I'm just boom
so that's the type of hardest assumption
we're going to look at
can you beat this trivial bound and now
we're going to use the standard notion
of average case orders in complexity
Theory uh but this notion of mild
average case hardness
so we say that a problem where a
function is mildly hot in average if
there exists some polynomial so that you
cannot compute it with probability
better than one minus one over p over
so maybe you can do it with one minus
one around
but if you cannot do it it would better
probability than one minus one over n
Square then it's mildly on average there
exists some polynomial maybe it's n
Square maybe it's n cubed okay
so maybe this is easy for one minus one
around but maybe it's still mildly hot
on average
and I can also clearly Define the same
way for approximating it that means I
should do it I should compute the C
approximation where I'm saying C
approximation I mean within additively C
the definition clear
okay so we're ready now to actually
formally State the theorem so the
theorem says the following things are
equivalent one with functions exist
there exists a polynomial such as
Katie's mildly heart on average
and in fact for every polynomial that's
just slightly slightly bigger than just
n the non-trivial thing
uh and every C
it's actually uh mind the holding
average to see Logan approximate
educated
so
there's a few different colors you can
get from this
I usually hate having more than uh two
two colors except black but I had to do
it here so I apologize for it it hurts
my eyes but I wanted to distinguish
between these different types of
colorless colorless
okay the first corollary it's red here
it's going to be a bad connection
between cryptography and uh and meta
complexity so just the the trivia
corollary that money functions exist if
only if KT is hot on average okay so KT
characterizes money functions
now I wanted to highlight these other
things which was not something we were
interested in but just popped out which
is into or interesting corollary is just
for logo complex in its own
and so the first thing we get is the
equivalence between these two things
so we get that we get an even approximal
result if this problem is hard to
compute exactly
then it's also how to approximate within
C Logan
so it's a login approximately result
these type of things were not known
before
and we still don't know how to do this
without going through cryptography
like without going through so this proof
is gonna as we'll see we'll go through a
bunch of cryptographic instructions to
pseudonym generators we still we don't
know how to achieve such a result that
doesn't talk about crypto at all right
it just talks about common complexity
without using this cryptographic
techniques
another thing
is this a decision to search a question
Legion Legion mentioned
so
it's actually not a great color how this
is stated but it turns out that this is
actually color of the the way it's
proved what we show is that actually if
this problem is is hard to compute
uh that's equivalent to saying it's
actually hard to find a witness so in
other words if you can compute KT you
can actually find a witness also
at least on average
you can find a k witness or Katie
witness
a minimal size program does it
again we don't know how to achieve these
type of things without going through
cryptography
and this is actually again a question
that was uh already in this uh as I
mentioned in the interactive survey
about what happened in 60s the call is
the constructive economical complexity
problem all these things equivalent and
we still don't know how to do it in the
worst case setting but in the average
case setting it turned out to the
equivalent
polynomial T is that exists in number
two yeah they're so basically it doesn't
matter you know if it's hot for some tea
then it's going to be hard for Altis
right here it says it exists some pretty
short and here you get a faulty
that again actually is not something
that's uh
I don't know maybe you can show that
other ways also I haven't thought of it
the hardness no so yeah if there if
there exists some tea then you're going
to want to function if you get a one
function you can prove hotness royalty
now I'm saying that the polynomial
itself in two depends on the polynomial
email that is or the function of the
hardness of the one-way no no it turns
like I said here because you see here
you can do for any startup ready if it's
hard for n Cube then you're going to
show it's hard for N squared
this is actually this relies on some
stupid padding arguments those type of
things
which you can do for one of your
functions but it's not clear how to do
padding actually so I don't know if you
can do this without it but our proof
goes through when it functions again one
of functions are Parable so you can rely
on like three properties about 20
functions
uh too but it's not clear how to do
padding for uh frequency
actually
Okay so
we're going to discuss the proof
probably in the in the next part of that
but before going there I'd like to just
point out that we're not obviously the
first to have this connection to the
cryptography and monitoring functions uh
as we already heard there's already been
this connection to the cryptography and
sorry cryptography and uh alcohol
complex matter complexities go back to
raspberry senkai and Alan
uh where it was shown that the existence
of one of functions imply worst case
hardness of KT
okay so this is a one-sided Direction
shown if one a functions exist then
create this worst case hard we still
don't know how to go back right we would
love to show that but going for Worse
get starters for KT that implies for any
function that would be amazing but we
still don't know it
okay
nevertheless it's going to be a starting
point for showing that when a function
is implied that KT is also hard on
average
so we're going to start off there and
have to work harder but also show
average case ordinance
also like to point out this very nice
work by role uh
from just actually a few years before
hours or one year before hours
Rahul actually conjecture that these
things should be equivalent
at least for mcsp
E I managed to show this he showed that
mcsp actually being hot of average
uh is harder average if only function is
under a new conjecture so you presented
a very nice conjecture
under which these two things are
equivalent
so Tyler kind of pointed towards that it
really should be exist such a such a
connection
um
okay so uh
now I'm going to try to give you this
overview of uh of this proof
and the real Prof goes by two in place
one implies three I'm not going to do
that I'm just going to show the easier
thing of just going from for one to two
then we don't have to deal with any of
these like annoying uh
uh paddings things for for running time
and uh
so we're going to show it in two steps
in the first step we're going to show
that if
KT is mylihood on average then when we
functions exist
and then we're going to show which funny
functions exist
then KT has to be hot on average
okay
this direction actually intuitively we
should be the easier One turns out that
that's a harder one to show okay this is
the one that we've already had in total
right we already knew that if we have
money functions we have prgs and prgs
can be killed off by mktp right
turns out that doesn't work so trivially
here because we only have an mkftp
oracle that works at high probability
and so we can actually not kill off
any PhD with the mktp Oracle that's
still an open problem actually whether
we can do that
so we'll have to work actually harder
to show that KT is mildly hot on average
and not just worst case on
this one uh actually it's going to be
very easy and we're going to actually
give you I'm going to give you uh the
almost the whole proof of this
okay so uh I still have two more minutes
or a few more minutes so I actually have
five more minutes four more minutes okay
so I'm gonna give you the construction
then we'll analyze it later and then you
will maybe have time to during the break
absorb the construction okay
so the goal here is we are showing that
if KT is hot on average we want to get a
one in function
no
there is this very nice result by Andy
young one of the original key results in
the foundations of cryptography that
says that to get that one-way function
we can actually suffices to get a weaker
concept called a weak body function
so what's a weak body function
a weak body function is really the mild
hot and average version of our one a
function
so remember in one function it's a
function it's easy to compute but really
really hard to go back right you can
only go back with very small probability
in this version
it suffices that there exists some
polynomial such that you cannot go back
with probability better than one minus
one over P of n so let's say you know
let's fix n Cube but you cannot invert
it
better than one minus one over n cubed
and the key point is if you have a one a
function like this then you can use
parallel repetition to get the strong
money function you just repeat it many
times
so what we will show here is that from
cologne complexity we can get the weak
body function and then we can use
yellows how this amplification theorem
to get a strong money function
let me only now mention a
one of the most important open problems
here if you would like to make this
practical
remove this step okay this step is
horrible in practice because it requires
you to actually repeat the function n
times
and that's going to kill basically all
practical efficiency
because now you need to have like an
n-square uh style construction and so
nobody's going to want to use that
so it would be really great if you could
get a construction that directly becomes
a strong money function
no it doesn't actually it doesn't work
we still actually uh
on it and let me mention another if you
don't care about practice of this
there's also a very important
theoretical implication of why this
sucks okay this prevents us from getting
like even if we strong start off with
the parable conjecture we assume that
mktp is there's nothing better in brute
for search
okay we still only get the one a
function that can be actually it's not
resilient against that because yeah here
is pretty shitty with respect to that
because now the security parameter is
much larger
you start off with something n and now
you have n per repetitions now it's n
Square
length but your security is only against
two trillion
so you've actually not gotten like full
exponential security
so this is also very important for from
practice for Theory yeah
that in the exponential security
question to weak web or something
yeah yeah so yeah you can get the weak
when it function with strong security
yeah yeah so it's it's equivalent yeah
yes but uh
exponential security
indeed but uh you know just because no
just because we don't know how to go
from a week to strong money functions in
a uh uh doesn't like doesn't mean that
we can't do it now going through KT
directly right maybe there's a Rex
construction and that will allow us to
uh in a kind of non-black box way maybe
go from with the strong running
functions I don't see like a reason why
it shouldn't I don't know
uh okay so
um I'm gonna take a break now and then
we'll move on to discussing the the
construction
[Applause]